je me suis dit hé bien pourquoi pas
prendre un peu de temps et se faire une
vidéo pour savoir comment vendre son
smartphone et surtout à quel prix de
vente parce que oui je donne toujours
des conseils des astuces pour acheter
des smartphones je vous présente plein
de nouveaux produits
quand on veut acheter un nouveau
smartphone il faut bien se séparer de
l'ancien ça sert à rien de les
collectionner pour avoir une vie après
quelqu'un d'autre pourrait l'avoir donc
il ya un vrai sens derrière tout ça
maintenant la question c'est comment
vont son smartphone par quel canal est
ce qu'il faut le vendre directement vous
de la main à la main ce qu'il faut le
vendre par internet
quelle est la bonne méthode ce qu'il ya
d'écrit un tabac donc ça soulève pas mal
de questions et le deuxième point c'est
à quel prix van tran smartphone c'est
toujours une grosse différence entre le
prix qu'on pense pouvoir ont tiré la
valeur en tout cas qu'on attribuait un
produit et la valeur réelle sur le
marché et puis surtout ce que les gens
veulent mettre derrière donc je vous ai
dit aujourd'hui à dégrossir tout ça on
va regarder ou vendre vos smartphones
dans les meilleures conditions pour en
tirer le meilleur prix possible
on va donc se concentrer sur le sujet du
jour savoir comment vendre son
smartphone dans les meilleures
conditions que vous allez voir on va
être extrêmement pragmatique vous avez
deux façons de vendre votre smartphone
votre ordinateur votre tablette ce que
vous voulez le premier ça va être auprès
d'un particulier et deuxième c'est un
vendeur professionnel dans le cas de la
vente 1 à particuliers vous pouvez
utiliser votre journal local pour vos
petites annonces à ses traits à
l'ancienne on peut en faire je sais pas
s'il ya beaucoup d'acheteurs qui passent
par là mais en tout cas si vous voulez
vous pouvez le faire aujourd'hui ce qui
marche beaucoup vous avez des sites
comme leboncoin le bon coin qui est
quand même aujourd'hui devenu une
référence dans son domaine et qui marche
extrêmement bien vous avez également
facebook ou même 6 mb pour facebook mais
c'est la marketplace la marketplace vous
avez beaucoup de monde qui vient acheter
et vendre vous avez également des sites
comme ebay
vous pouvez venir vendre vous
directement enfin il ya pas mal de
possibilités pour venir vendre de
particulier à particulier tout ça c'est
pas mal de faire vraiment attention
parce que vous pouvez rapidement tomber
sur des arnaques dis pas que c'est tout
le temps le cas parce que bien
évidemment ce nom ces sites n'existerait
pas mais il faut faire extrêmement
attention pour savoir comment sert payer
ce qu'il faut absolument proscrire et
éviter ce sont les chèques l'échec c'est
noël n'y a rien de pire pour ce drama
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
éventuellement ses paypal vous êtes
sécurisé au niveau des transactions
paypal aussi ses limites je vous le
détailler dans quelques instants il ya
également le
virements bancaires sous couvert de
faire les vérifications méfiez-vous du
talion si dans quelques instants
et si vous avez le saint graal c'est
l'espèce vous avez l'argent directement
dans votre main petain échanges et pour
ça il faut effectivement pouvoir sans
contrat que la personne est souvent par
internet à des problèmes de distance
physique la première chose que je vous
recommanderais c'est d'aller là où il ya
de l'audience là où il ya du monde donc
autant dire que le journal local le
petit canard du coin c'est bien pour
avoir des informations par contre pour
venir vendre
peut-être dans une tranche d'âge très
élevé pour du smartphone pour une montre
pour une tablette pour en or 10 quel que
soit le produit je suis pas sûr que ce
soit l'idéal il faut aller sur des sites
où il ya beaucoup d'audience le bon coin
facebook marketplace
il ya beaucoup de monde ça marche bien
il est de la même manière vous avez
beaucoup de monde il ya donc plusieurs
solutions plusieurs canaux à venir
essayer tester ont trouvé ce lieu de foi
qui vous corresponde mieux gagner
évidemment il faudra nous fassiez vous
même la photo de votre produit il faudra
rédiger une description complète sans
faute d'orthographe ils sont rassurés
quand même un petit peu
évitez de donner vos coordonnées passer
par les systèmes de messagerie des sites
pour éviter qu on vous passe un coup de
fil en permanence et combien de vous
déranger vous savez pas qui vous avez
affaire de l'autre côté il vous faudra
fournir une attestation de vente vous
faites en deux exemplaires un pour vous
un pour l'autre vendu le tac tac tac tac
numéro imei très très important pour
donner le numéro d'identification du
smartphone donc on va quand même qu'on a
quelques contraintes
après vient la question délicate du
paiement pour moi le mieux c'est
l'espèce entendez-vous bien sûr le tarif
avant de vous rencontrer la personne va
juste être là pour vérifier que le
produit fonctionne
évitez les négociations sur place soyez
très clair là dessus si vous êtes à
distance vous avez deux moyens de
paiement qui fonctionne bien paypal
helviens m'ont alors paypal c'est bien
mais fait extrêmement gaffe parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d' arnaque qui circulent sur
les sites à savoir que quelqu'un vous
dit ok je vous écris ce produit je
trouve bien je vais me le payer pourquoi
pas un peu plus cher que le tarif que
vous en voulez donc à vous de ces
extrêmement alléchant ok on y va la
personne vous dis je vous fais un
virement paypal
donnez moi votre email il vous ce dos
fait un virement et vous recevez en tout
cas un email avec la tête de paypal le
même email que paypal vous enverrai vous
marquants vous avez reçu tel et tel
montant qui était crédité sur votre
compte
vérifiez bien les mails d'envoi et
surtout connectez vous à votre compte
paypal pour voir si l'argent est
effectivement crédité ou non il ya
beaucoup d'armes a que là-dessus si vous
vendez par paypal et que la personne
nous a effectivement payer par paypal
il ya un point qu'il faut vraiment
connaître c'est que paypal protège les
vendeurs mais surtout les acheteurs
la transaction est fait la personne a le
produit est au bout de quelques jours à
personne dit au final ce produit ne va
pas il ya un problème je ne veux plus je
ne souhaite plus eh bien je
il est donc contacté paypal en disant je
souhaite annuler il ya un problème il
sourit grecque n'est pas le faire
l'intermédiaire est va trancher
la plupart du temps pour l'acheteur en
disant vous devez rembourser la personne
elle va vous renvoyer le produit
novateur paypal c'est qu'ils vont
prendre l'argent de votre compte ils
vont le rendre à la personne ensuite est
la discrétion de la personne de vous
renvoyer le produit
oui ou non il faut savoir que souvent il
ya des arnaques et que les personnes ne
renvoie pas nécessairement les produits
auquel cas vous n'avez plus l'argent et
vous ne récupérez pas le produit sauf si
vous tombez sur des personnes qui bien
évidemment sont bien intentionnées mais
il faut toujours être méfiant ce que je
vous conseille à ce moment là si vous
êtes à distance c'est fonctionner par un
virement bancaire datant déclare jean
soit sur votre compte vous appelez la
banque pour vérifier une fois que c'est
ok vous pouvez envoyer le produit donc
ça c'est vraiment les points connaître
lorsque vous êtes en particulier et vous
avez affaire à des particuliers et pour
éviter tout ça vous retrouvez les
vendeurs professionnels du côté du
professionnel vous en avoir tous les
magasins qui sont dans votre ville
proche de chez vous ou pas dont vous
retrouverez souvent dans le nom le terme
cache qu'ils vont racheter vos produits
contre l'espèce vous vous rendez votre
produit rapidement certes mais par
contre vous n'allez pas en toucher grand
chose ça c'est vraiment à privilégier si
vous avez besoin d'argent tout de suite
selon être et du chant et que vous ne
pouvez pas patienter vous avez également
des sites de marques comme samsung ou
autres qui vont pouvoir reprendre vos
smartphones sous couvert en acheter un
nouveau dans leur boutique vous allez
avoir également les sites des opérateurs
que ce soit bull telecom sfr et
compagnie lorsque vous allez acheter un
nouveau smartphone et bien ils vont
pouvoir reprendre votre ancien
smartphone est ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que bien souvent lorsque vous
allez passer par des sites de marquer
par des opérateurs et bien eu une passe
par des sites qui font du reconditionnés
lorsqu'on vient vendre son smartphone il
ya un point à prendre en considération
un point et un seul c'est ce qu'on
appelle la valeur résiduelle à savoir
quelle est la valeur de votre smartphone
à l'instant t
certaines marques ont une valeur
résiduelle très fortes notamment apple
ça veut dire vous allez acheter un
smartphone d'apple allait imaginons 1000
euros et bien au bout de un an il lui
restera une valeur de peut-être 700
euros au bout de deux ans peut-être 500
euros là où d'autres marques qui au bout
de un an n'auront plus une valeur
résiduelle que 2 400 euros et au bout de
deux ans
250 euros sur un smartphone qui coûtait
à la base également 1000 euros donc ça
c'est aussi un point à prendre vraiment
considération et notamment lorsque vous
allez acheter un smartphone on va donc
essayer de voir quelle est la valeur
résiduelle de votre produit c'est à dire
à quel prix vous pouvez le vendre
honnêtement sans que la personne qui
l'achètent se sentent arnaquer et sans
que vous vous soyez lésés pour autant
voilà comment on va procéder
on va se dire qu'on veut un samsung
galaxy s 10 ans smartphones de l'année
dernière il a un écran qui a quand même
plusieurs micros rayures pas énormément
mais un petit peu le dos également
quelques rayures par contre il prend
extrêmement bien la charge l'autonomie
est plutôt bonne les boutons fonctionne
bien
voilà donc à quoi va ressembler notre
produit on va donc se connecter dans un
premier temps sur le bon coin pour
essayer de voir à quel prix les gens
vendent leur samsung galaxy s 10 que
recherchez-vous je vais taper samsung
galaxy s 10 l'agent des 1 400 euros
alors je clique il marque sun semble
très bon état auquel très bon état je
pense que ça veut dire c'est 1 500 12
giga de stockage c'est donc un des
modèles les plus haut de gamme on est
sur un smartphone qui est sorti il ya un
an et quatre mois et qui coûtait
celui-là on rit plus de 1000 euros et
voyez on a 400 euros fonctionne
parfaitement à tous ses accessoires
boîte charge ok bon jusque là tout va
bien vendu partie fans salut tiffany
maintenant je valais sur la marketplace
de facebook vorace que ça va dire
samsung galaxy s 10 de la même manière
un x10 voyez là j'en ai bien ici et côté
de chez moi à clermont ferrand à 400
euros
samsung galaxy s dissegna son atelier
giga de stockage donc déjà je suis quand
même un peu plus petit et là par contre
je le trouve également à 400 euros sur
une version 128 go de stockage sas et
margot qu'il pense à lui margot on sait
donc la valeur de revente d'un samsung
galaxy s 10 va les voir maintenant ce
que va nous proposer date market et
compagnie pour effectivement réussir à
voir quelle est la cote de notre produit
soit pouvoir bien en retirer
je tiens à préciser que cette vidéo
n'est pas sponsorisé par personne par
qui que ce soit c'est juste pour
illustrer mon propos que souhaitez vous
vendre alors je veux vendre un téléphone
la marque c'est samsung galaxy s galaxy
s 10 quelle est sa capacité on va partir
sur le 128 votre produit est-il
débloqués pour tout opérateur
oui et c'est là que ça devient très
intéressant c'est là on peut souvent se
faire avoir dans quel état est l'écran
intacte ça pour moi quasiment aucun
smartphone est intacte même si vous
cochez intacte et voulant renvoyer ils
vont l'expertisé s'il estime qu'il n'est
pas intact le prix va baisser intacte
pour moi vous l'aurez jamais micro
rayures rayures cassé et c'est là où
c'est très très dur comment est ce que
vous pouvez juger si ce sont des
micro rayures ou des rayures convois
sont des micros réglés quel est l'état
de la coque
il ya des micros rayures également
peut-être même des rayures mais bon j'ai
mis une coque de protection donc on va
dire des micros rayures votre produit-il
fonctionnel bien évidemment et il me
proposa 300 prend 4 euros ça veut dire
que potentiellement le produit je vais
leur envoyer s'il considère
effectivement ils cochent toutes les
cases et bien il nous racontera 334
euros si par contre il considère que
l'écran il n'y a pas de micro rayures
mederi dur et bien je passe à 300 euros
donc dans le meilleur des cas je
toucherai 301 euros
on va maintenant aller faire un tour du
côté d'un site d'opérateurs qui est
bouygues telecom parce qu'eux aussi ils
reprennent votre smartphone entrée la
marque de haute garonne
alors on va taper de la même manière
samsung galaxy s 10 votre téléphone
présentiez un extérieur abîmé non
rayures ou impact superficielles oui
rayures ou impact prononcé fissures
fente moi je vais dire non l'appareil
s'allume t-il correctement oui bien
évidemment les boutons à l'écran
sont-ils fonctionnel oui ils sont
fonctionnels et là il me le propose à
200 euros
on va aller sur un autre site de vente
en reconditionnant qui s'appelle
ribaille donc on est toujours samsung le
galaxy s 10 taille de la mémoire 128 go
de stockage votre appareil fonctionnel
oui parfaitement est ce que votre
appareil est bloqué chez un opérateur
non absolument pas quel est l'état de la
batterie très bon état la batterie est
durée de vie normale évaluer l'état de
l'écran je veux dire qu'il est en bon
état très bon état c'est compliqué il
est en bon état une fois de plus c'est
toujours difficile à jauger quel est
l'état de la face arrière je dire qu'il
est en bon état
avez-vous le câble de chargement de
l'appareil oui veuillez supprimer tous
les comptes associés ok je suis comme
tous les comptes associés et on lui
propose à 309 euros
mais on arrive quand même à quel tarif
on peut trouver neuf sur amazon je peux
trouver à 579 euros
589 euros dochia deux choses a vraiment
retenir là dessus la première c'est si
vous voulez le voir par vous-mêmes bien
évidemment nous à gagner plus d'argent
la deuxième c'est si vous voulez pas
vous embêter vous le vendez un
professionnel puisque le particulier
peut venir râler il peut y avoir des
problèmes des comptes renégociation vous
ne savez jamais à qui vous avez affaire
donc ça peut être intéressant de vendre
un professionnel puisque vous achetez
votre sécurité
moi je verrais vraiment comme ça il faut
donc trouver le bon acteur qui vous le
reprend dans les meilleures conditions
mais une fois de plus il faut être
vraiment honnête lorsque vous remplissez
le questionnaire dernier point très
important et non des moindres surtout
lorsque vous vendez votre smartphone à
un particulier pour ses biens bien le
formater à supprimer tous vos comptes
tous
masson personnels qui sont dans le
smartphone au moment où vous aller les
vendre voilà pour les infos que vous
donnez pour savoir comment vendre votre
smartphone
à quel prix a vous de me dire maintenant
si les astuces que je n'aurais pas
évoquer vous peu mes marques et bien
évidemment en bas en commentaire sur ce
je donne rendez vous extrêmement
rapidement pour continuer par l'état qui
croyez moi il ya plein de choses qui
arrivent ou de l'amour a très vite
ciao
[Musique]
ce
ça
ce week-end
com
[Musique]